[Music]
in feces is flavor news I was drinking
as you said that I don't
man I just whoo that set stuff submitted
by sitting on a toilet ah my favorite
spots my favorite spots my friend
recorded that me married is sitting on
the toilet she wasn't holding it up like
that so far he posted he posted it wait
that's from something now flush toilets
my prison Chocolate Rain are you tasting
de vie Tay Zonday I met him once and he
wasn't that nice chocolate well he's
socially awkward summer Walker socially
awkward to some our Walker do you guys
know her no surprise there in Indian
city says burning cow dung is a crucial
part of its street vendors success do
they use it for like their coals to cook
oh that's crazy
coal and cow dung cakes cupcakes to like
yeah to like heat up their food and
stuff and now there's this one does it
taste good no no they're saying that
that's what makes it
oh no wait wait wait back up
have you seen Cal Dookie it's full of
like hey instead they got no digestive
worn on that grass is just getting your
hey whatever hey is it's it's just
getting through so it's highly flammable
how did they get so buff I don't get
where'd you get the flavor from the
smokiness of the burning grass so sir
they're cooking with it yes as like like
chocolate lame yeah yeah and and yeah
and cold and so they're saying that this
city in India after the air quality had
declined to severe levels that's when
the state government banned the domestic
burning of cow dung and cold they're
like hey before you [ __ ] regulate us
why don't you just stop those driving
cars yeah well they did they had like a
whole thing where they were only
allowing like half the cars to drive
each day they were like if you have a
even number license plate you can drive
one day and then if you have an odd
number license plate you can drive the
other they're doing that in China too
yeah yeah I don't know if it's working
or not it sucks if you live there yeah
definitely but I mean it probably sucks
like regardless to win what if the
ambulance is even ambulance on the day
that you need the brakes well yes so
because of that they're saying that
about 5,000 street food vendors in this
city they're saying that their
livelihoods are under threat because the
cow-dung and the coal is what flavor is
their food they use cows are sacred in
India right so they don't they can't eat
the cow yay
so now they can't use them for fuel what
are they doing with all that cow dung
now I know you can't cook with it is
throwing it away
fertilizer 5000 street vendors that does
produce a lot of support oh I kind of
want to smell it like burn some and
smell it no I mean I don't need to burn
it I could drive the Oxnard right now
and that [ __ ] smells yeah oh yes
yeah well maybe it was a different smell
of it burns cuz I found out about like
burning animal [ __ ] for like fuel and
like food or or whatever in this
documentary documentary about like how
they cook in Mongolia like winter they
don't have trees and [ __ ] like this so
they gotta use a horse [ __ ] so they just
have what they just collect the horse
[ __ ] and then D just like burn that
[ __ ] and just throw a goat on it
or something I did not know that that
was that flammable at all
I guess dry I guess dry though cuz like
you're imagining wet right yeah but
imagine if it's like all dried out and
stuff like using like old ass like cow
cow [ __ ] or whatever you ever step on a
dry one step on it's really crunchy it
is like a big disgusting diarrhea cookie
it's like a grassy diarrhea cookie
that's how you know it's gonna be fun
yeah
what city was this yeah it's a city
called Hana Hana in India I really I'm
just curious now what the food tastes
like yeah I was gonna say like like a
[ __ ] pie you got a wonder about the
flavor of the food as it stands already
before it's like guarantee it's the
coals that probably make it taste good
and not the cow [ __ ] fumes I need my cow
[ __ ] it's essential for the dishes
distinct have they tried it without so
the government had promised to supply
vendors with gas canister stoves to roof
it's not the same taking a bite out of
the food they're like where's the smoky
rich flavor they won't let me do it
anymore
what is he cooking I would totally eat
that [ __ ] these guys I'm surprised they
don't have like a cow on there ah what
is that uh what kind of advertisement is
that this is a celebrity that had
visited there oh that was a big day for
them that looks like a stream
yeah protests or something like that
does that looks like congregating like
he's about to get saved or or take over
a country or something but you know
carts like that are good though best if
I went to India that's the food I want
to I'm going to the streets first so I
was I was walking as our foodie scene
that with Andrew Zimmern
he always says have you the best way of
what getting sick is by avoiding
drinking the water if you drink bottled
water but then like sometimes I'll cook
with water or like they'll give so I
give it's like a cold dish then they'll
use water to prepare it some
I'm like a [ __ ] so I think if you
weren't for that I don't know I just
need everything I would have to if I'm
in India and knuckle under no McDonald's
cuz I'm trying to avoid the runs I got
it I gotta try the you just deal with
the runs yeah you only live once man you
gotta eat food that makes you go am I
gonna get dengue fever I'm gonna die all
over when I was going because of the
mosquitoes
what disease oh you get from mosquito
bite
I don't know it's a tropical disease
though I can't believe celebrity
advertising works on people okay I've
never really I've never been moved by a
celebrity have you never seen a picture
go Oh Will Smith eat that one that's his
favorite one I give me the Will Smith
burger never but how do you even know if
it's his favorite because he probably
went there once and then they were like
oh that's good a photo I think he's like
[ __ ] this was recommended by my friend
even liked it but all right it's like
that so like but I know out there
there's some old guy who's watching a
commercial with his wife and he's like
Shaq likes Gold Bond we should use gold
do you think that there's a cresting
point in which you just get old enough
that you're just you just trust
celebrity endorsements after that it
could be because I'm hoping that that
happens to you 90% of the world though
could your celebrity endorsements for
everything from perfume do we get brand
deals ourselves and people [ __ ] you
got celebrities somebody's like man
Steve uses that oh man I think people
would use the opposite or what Steve's
hair shampoo perfect I'm striking in a
list we use do some anti brand deals are
the only brands hire you to like
sabotage other brands and oh yeah I
think that's the next next wave that's
true let's sponsor the people that we'd
hold on yeah just like hear someone's
like you're super [ __ ] up to you
something like yeah use occult use
Colgate Pepsi they would use each other
how come all friends don't do that
like what cuz that that just makes it
awkward Pepsi taste tests in the 90s it
was a big deal
outside the grocery store Pepsi actually
won yeah you gotta be you got to choose
a side though some [ __ ] though can't
even like vote Pepsi did not win she
paid to win we're using cow done when
they remain do they can bring back let's
not say and it's better free teeth
anyways isn't just for tinting oh I
guess not for the acidity of you know
coke makes more money with Pepsi around
than if they eliminated the competition
really I saw this whole documentary on
their battle and then there was a point
where they were gonna completely take
over but then like they help Pepsi stay
alive
I mean cuz they were just like just for
the selection just like the competition
makes the market healthy yeah that's
what you know the branding agency we
worked with for barbell that's was
explaining to me so he was like I was
telling him about like some of my fears
of what I thought would be I guess
threats to accompany me goes no you want
competitors you want as many competitors
as possible because what ends up
happening is the pie gross he goes you
don't want to be the only slice of pie
on a small pie is you're never gonna
make that much money you actually want
the pie be this huge and if there's 20
competitors now the market shares this
big and now your goal is to steal
everyone else's market share but then if
the fifth the pie is never that big you
can never have a big pie so uber needs
lift they need live and they would
prefer ibly there's like four other
brands that come out so mom and pop like
department stores they see Amazon over
across the street and they're like we
welcome to the fight friend slow is a
right before is even built you read it
in the newspaper your line well I'm
closing early we're done all the
downtown shops are [ __ ] boarded up
man like a hurricane's coming Main
Street is I'd love to see it oh my doing
all right chef bae's us meeting you
buddy bassist game on friend your
American spirit of competition
what's hell of depressing is when you
see the Walmart close though when you
when the Walmart or whatever I've seen
some documentaries and stuff about like
the last Walmart in this small little
coal mining town is closing and that's
when you know the town is [ __ ] done
for Twitter that suck them dry and then
they [ __ ] leave there's no more money
at all though and the Walmart closes
when Walmart as big as their decides
like wow there's no more money in this
town then matter yeah and then it's
crazy could assume that steps in dude
Walmart is no different than an alien
race sucking all the resources up and
then being like okay these let's go find
another planet guys Silver Surfer
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you